- Create a picture graph to show
how many wands each fairy owns.
So Glenda owns two wands,
Tink owns three wands,
Merry owns four wands, and
Gracie owns five wands.
And in our picture graph,
each picture of a wand
represents one wand, it
is equal to one wand,
it means one wand.
All right, so Glenda has two wands.
So let's see, I'll click
one, two wands for Glenda.
Tink has three wands.
So I'm gonna have one,
two, three wands for Tink.
Merry has four wands, so I'll have
one, two, three, four wands for Merry.
And then Gracie has five wands.
So I'm gonna have one, two, three, four,
five wands for Gracie.
Let me check my answer, let's keep going,
this is actually a lot of fun.
The zookeeper measured four penguins.
Their heights were 40, 44,
48, and 48 centimeters.
Make a line plot of their heights.
So a line plot, we have
a number line here,
and we wanna put a dot,
as many dots as we have,
at a certain measurement.
So we have one penguin
that it was 40 centimeters,
so at 40 we have one
penguin right over there.
We have another penguin
that's at 44 centimeters.
So we put 44 right over there.
And then we have two
penguins at 48 centimeters.
So we could put two dots right over there.
Two penguins at 48 centimeters.
So there you go.
That is our line plot.
Let's keep going, this is a lot of fun.
There are five books on the shelf.
The heights of the books are 32, 36, 38,
32, and 35 centimeters.
Make a line plot of the heights.
So let's see, there is one
book that is 32 centimeters.
Then there is a book
that is 36 centimeters.
that is 38 centimeters.
Then there is another book
that is 32 centimeters.
So we actually have two books,
one, two books that are at 32 centimeters.
And then one book that is at 35.
So there you go, I made the line plot.
And remember, all a line
plot is is it's essentially
counting how many of each height we have.
We have two at 32 centimeters,
one at 35 centimeters,
one at 36, and one at 38.
Let's do one more of these.
Robin Hood measured four arrows.
The lengths were 26, 26,
23, and 25 centimeters.
Make a line plot of the lengths.
So we have two arrows that were 26,
that were 26 centimeters.
So on 26 on our number line here
I'm gonna put two dots.
We have an arrow that's 23 centimeters,
so I'll put one dot there.
And then I have one arrow
that is 25 centimeters.
So I'll put a dot there.
And we're done.